well initially it made me
feel like myself it was like this
miracle
Sal where suddenly all of the
unconscious anxiety and sense of
difference between myself and others
seemed to vanish and that discomfort in
my own skin turned into Comfort like I
suddenly felt like oh maybe this is how
everyone else feels all the time I've
discovered this thing where now I feel
like okay like I can exhale and I can be
around other people every time I had
done something or said something that I
regretted it was when I was drinking and
I thought at one
point maybe I don't want to live a life
where I'm continually or even
sporadically wishing that I hadn't said
or done something